there's a thing called the monster group
which is a beautiful very large
symmetrical thing we're gonna have a
look at what's called the monster group
that's a really really cool man now
there's never been any kind of
explanation of why it's there and it's
obviously not there just by coincidence
okay so groups are algebraic structures
that arise naturally in the study of
symmetry now that can be symmetry now
sort of a vast range of different
contexts let's take a geometric form any
sort of geometric shapes us take an
equilateral triangle okay and let's
label the vertices 1 2 & 3 when I
consider the symmetries of an
equilateral triangle so what what I'm
really thinking about here are locations
and reflections ok so these are natural
symmetries of this triangle for example
we can consider certain rotations about
that center point
okay now let's let's write down this
these collections of symmetries let's
call this collection G if I sort of
think of putting a pin in the paper at
that center point and then moving the
triangle around well I can rotate
through certain angles and the triangle
will move back onto itself ok I have to
be careful which angle I choose here but
sort of it's not too difficult to see
that I could say to rotate through 120
degrees that's why there are 120 that
would have the effect of permuting those
vertices the corners of the triangle and
I could also go through say 240 degrees
and they're really the only two
non-trivial rotations that I can do
which will move that triangle back onto
itself because 360 doesn't care
well 360 does count Ashley and that's
really an important one so let's
actually include that one we're gonna
need there to get this idea of a group
so let's call that R 0 that means do
nothing I guess nothing to do nothing
symmetry that's really really important
in the contact of a group ok so we've
got our rotations now what else have you
got let's consider sort of mirror
symmetry okay so we could think about
putting a mirror down that line and that
would also give us a symmetry of the of
the triangle ok it would fix the top
vertex never swap these two bottom
corners
ok so let's call that a so let's include
that over here and then similarly we
have B and C ok so we've got three lines
of reflectional symmetry of this
triangle as well ok so a B and C so what
if we went down here these are it's not
too difficult to check that this is this
is a complete set of symmetries of the
air-quality or triangle got six of them
in total
this is what's called the symmetry group
of the equatorial triangle the key
contact with the group is it's more than
just a collection of symmetries there's
a rule or there's an operation which
allows us to combine two symmetries
together so if we take two symmetries we
could we could take the first one and
combine it with the second and that will
give us a third symmetry of the triangle
okay let me give you an example so let's
say consider let's draw this triangle
out again little bit smaller so I've got
on one two three
okay let's actually see what happens to
the vertices when we apply this symmetry
so let's say apply let's do a okay okay
so a we defined it to be this reflection
in this vertical line of symmetry here
so what does that do to the do to the
vertices well it swaps the bottom two
okay so it looks like that that's what
would that will look like after we've
applied that reflectional symmetry and
let's do another one let's now follow
that up with say our anti-clockwise
rotation through a hundred and twenty
degrees okay now what does that give us
okay so what does that mean so this
becomes 2 this is 1 and this is 3 ok so
that's what we've got now we could have
gone straight from the initial triangle
to this end triangle with just one
operation what would that operation be
well what have we done here we've fixed
the bottom right vertex through Yuma
swapped these two well that corresponds
to what we call C okay that's that
reflection so we've got C okay so what
we could do we could write that down
sort of mathematically are 120 composed
with a equals C what we're trying to do
here is we're trying to define a sort of
like a multiplication on this set okay
so it's like a fit like a some sort of
natural operation which allows us to
combine these two symmetries together
and get another one that's really that's
really what's going on and that's really
the key idea of a group it's a
collection of objects with some
operation defined on it which satisfies
these sort of properties this is the
amplitude this allows us to define an
abstract notion of a group so this
object here this is the set this is the
collection of symmetries I can have a
group strictly speaking is this
collection of symmetries together with
this rule for combining symmetries
together we can
perhaps try and understand groups by
breaking them up into smaller pieces the
analogy to keep in mind here is the idea
of factorizing a positive number into
prime factors okay so this should be
familiar to everybody okay now we can do
something like that for a group it's a
little bit more subtle it's a little bit
more complicated let's say 60 is 2 times
2 times 3 times 5 and those numbers I
just said were all prime numbers in
group theory there's a sort of
similar-sounding theorem that every
group is composed of a number of prime
groups except the term is simple groups
they're not actually terribly simple
let's just consider let me call R here
let's just consider the rotations ok so
let's forget about the reflections for a
second ok now as I said you can talk
about that you have this notion of an
abstract group now R itself is actually
a group ok it's not the symmetry group
of the equilateral triangle it's the
rotation it's the group of rotational
symmetries of their control triangle
it's like a subset but it's what we call
a subgroup and they say it's not just
any old subset the key property is that
it first of all it has the do-nothing
element that's really important and the
other key property were looking for here
is that it's this set is closed under
this operation that we defined in other
words if I take two rotations in here
and combine them then I get another
element of that particular set I can't
combine two rotations together and then
suddenly get a reflection that's not
going to happen we can easily check that
ok so that's the key property that this
is actually a subgroup ok so that's R
and let's define s to take ok we're
gonna have our 0 in there we're going to
need our 0 in any of our in any of our
subgroups us this key do-nothing element
let's just take a now this has got three
elements and this has got two elements
and again this set s is a subgroup
because if you do if you compose a with
itself that's a reflection don't twice
but gets you are zero with us the do
nothing not to do nothing operation yeah
that's right so it must be yeah that's
why so I mean it must contain the do
nothing element and it must have the
property that if I take any two elements
in that smaller subset by combine them
then I stay inside that set that's the
key thing we're looking for here it's
not too hard to see that we actually can
write G as R times s as a sort of a
factorization what this means is
whenever what I've written down here is
that every
of this of this symmetry group G is a
product of something in our with
something in s okay so that's why we
might say that this is a factorization
of G into two smaller pieces okay so
these things are what are called simple
groups so the idea would be then to try
and understand all groups or not or in
other words to try to understand all
possible types of symmetry can we give a
complete description of what all these
basic building blocks all these atoms of
symmetry what they actually look like
okay so this has been sort of a
fundamental problem in group theory in
algebra for more than a hundred years
what's remarkable is that it is actually
possible to do this okay so there's this
there's a theorem called the
classification of finite simple groups
which was announced around 1980 which
provides us with this a periodic table
of symmetry that's right it's up on the
wall that's right okay so what what is
this there and then so it's it's um it's
this think incredible amazing result
that describes what all the finite
simple groups look like so this is a
really very unique theorem in all the
mathematics I mean it was a huge
international collaborative effort to
prove this there over many many decades
it's proof runs to between 10,000 and
100,000 pages and it was done by three
or four hundred mathematicians I don't
think anybody's read through the whole
proof it's sort of an incredible
incredible achievement really or
something one of the highlights of 20th
century mathematics there were some
mistakes in it in anything as long as
that they are bound to be some mistakes
so it's not terribly worrying there are
some mistakes in this what we're looking
to do is we're just trying to sort of
identify various families of simple
groups so for example one family will be
all of the groups which have size a
prime number okay then we don't know
what all the primes look like of course
there's infinitely many of them but but
we can give a descriptive definition of
this particular family and it turns out
there's various other infinite families
of simple groups which are a little more
difficult to define so I won't do that
here but there's various other infinite
families otherwise they don't all have
to have size a prime number okay so it's
a little bit more complicated than sort
of the factorization of integers what
what's what's really interesting about
this theorem is that we have these
various infinite families
come up but there were some exceptions
okay so there's it turns out it's sort
of remarkable fact that there are 20
exactly 26 finite simple groups which do
not belong to any of these infinite
families they're like black sheep yeah
they they refuse to belong to any of
these any of these sort of well-known
well behaved groups exactly twenty-six
of them yeah so these are what are
called the sporadic simple groups okay
so now they have a long long history so
the first five of them were discovered
in the 1860s 1870s and then the sixth
one wasn't discovered until about 100
years later in the 1960s and then over
the subsequent 10-15 years a further 20
of these sporadic groups were discovered
and this all came out of this intensive
effort going into the proof for the
classification theory in this enormous
enormous project
the result is probably true and I don't
it's not incredible as I don't
understand it
I mean it's the the fact of the theorem
is true
apparently and it's we don't know why
it's true and this is where the monster
comes in because the monster group is
the largest of these sporadic simple
groups yeah that's right so as you say
we're group is a collection of
symmetries or collection of elements
with respect to some operation and
largest just means you know in terms of
the number of the number of members of
this of this particular group so the
monster is it's not unique it's just the
biggest of this of a group of outline
well yeah I mean it's a unique a unique
incentive there's only one there's only
one monster okay you can say it that by
there's only one monster but it's it's a
unique defining poverty might be to say
that it's a simple group which is one of
these twenty-six Braddock's and has my
father largest order so it sort of like
the Big Daddy of all these sporadic
groups and in fact quite a few of the
other 26 Braddock the other 25 sporadic
sort of live inside the monster in some
sense not all of them do but but many of
them can be found in some way inside the
monster so it's like a bit like a bit
a mother group for these sporadic simple
groups we're talking absolutely enormous
chili so let me let me see if I can
write this down so what are we looking
at so so we use n to denote the monster
okay and this denotes the size okay and
what is this thing so okay let's write
it out in full in full detail okay so
it's a big numbers I hope we've got a
bit of time for this so I'm going to run
out of space let me continue down here
still coming on so eight and then a code
nine zeroes on the end so this is
approximately 8 times 10 to the 53 okay
that's the size of the monster that's
how many symmetries that's right so I
mean we sort of talked about a group as
being sort of the symmetry group of some
object so the monster can be defined in
this way as well it is the symmetry
group of some structure so at the start
of our little talk
you showed me an equilateral triangle
yep and we looked at at symmetries right
what does the object for which the
monster group represents cemeteries like
like okay well this is pretty difficult
this is pretty difficult it's quite a
simple thing to try and explain I think
of them as Christmas tree ornaments you
can hang you know sometimes you see a
Christmas tree ornament which has a
number of spikes coming out of it and
it's covered all over with silvery paint
or paper or something and it turns
around and then from some points of view
you see it has fivefold symmetry and
then oh look it's refill symmetry right
now and so on it is the symmetry group
of some structure it's not as simple as
an equilateral triangle we can't draw on
a piece of paper unfortunately we can't
even think about it in three-dimensional
space so it turns out the initial
construct the the construction of the
monster relies on the existence of some
mathematical structure in high
dimensional space and this and the
monsters the symmetry group of this
object and the number of dimensions
we're talking about here is a hundred
and ninety six thousand eight hundred
and eighty-three so this is a very
difficult thing to try and try and
picture in our minds
why 190 6800 matey three that's just the
way it is like I know that's a lot of
dimensions but it seems arbitrarily
small at the same time it seems strange
that there's this cutoff number and
there's nothing else above it seems such
an exact number yeah I mean this is the
business with sporadic groups I mean
this is why they're so fascinating I
mean why do only 26 of them why not 27
why not 28 do they belong
can we sort of fit them into some other
infinite family of groups but it's it's
a sort of a bit of a mystery but this is
that these are the numbers that come out
with this of this classification theorem
it was a famous thing yeah for sure I
mean the monster group I mean simple
groups being these basic building blocks
of of symmetry I mean these are these
are sort of a center of study in in in
group theory and so the monster plays a
central role in that because of its
starring role as the largest of these
products sometimes I think of these
things isn't not like Christmas tree
ornaments but like gems most people like
jewelry you know because the light
sparkles and somehow there's a slight
prism effect so that you may see you
know even if it's illuminated with white
light you may say you had some greens
and blues and so on they look nice well
so did these things in higher
dimensional space except that I haven't
got 186 thousand eight hundred and
eighty three dimensional eyes so I'll
never see them but the actual study of
the monster group is quite a niche
subject mean people there are there are
small group of people who've really
dedicated their careers to really
understanding and probing the structure
of this group and so a lot a lot is
known about the monster I'm you know a
lot about its internal structure but
it's subgroups like we saw here in the
subgroups of of this symmetry group
adecco actual triangle we do know quite
a lot about it but there still a lot of
things to be to be fully understood it's
a difficult very due to its size it's
it's a very difficult group to work with
I would just like to know what it's all
about you know why it's there and every
now and then I've often said I've said
for 25 or 30 years that the one thing
I'd wee
like to know before I die is why the
monster group exists you have the
monster here then the second largest one
is called the baby monster no not
someone called moths actually no so
that's the baby monster the monster the
only ones I think which don't have that
have that property you haven't got the
hope but probably you don't care either
I care I'd like to understand what the
hell's going on if you forgive me for
expressing it like that